and his wife was her son's friend Chris
Rock took aim at Will Smith during his
selective outrage Netflix comedy special
over the weekend one year after the
actor slapped him at the Oscars
oh wow referencing the cheating rumors
that surrounded will and his wife Jada
Pinkett Smith in 2020. I
didn't talk about this
but for some reason these put back on
the internet
I have no idea why two talented people
would do something that low down I got
into an entanglement with
August that's what I said an
entanglement yes
a relationship yes it was a relationship
absolutely I was in a lot of pain and I
was very broken she hurt him way more
than he hurt me and who's he hit me now
a source tells ET that Will and Jada
have been on a journey of healing over
the last year and have put a lot of
effort into their relationship it's easy
to love somebody if they do everything
you want if they act how you want them
to act and they don't do anything you
you don't want them to do but you know
Jaden and I have you know we weathered
some storms and that that's really for
me the the only way that you can get to
the other side
ET Source says that following the whole
Oscar's ordeal will took time off to
focus on his mental state the incident
truly brought Will and Jada closer
together he took accountability for his
actions and Jada stood by him throughout
this hard time in their lives
there is no part of me
that thinks that was the right way
to behave in that moment will issued an
apology on Instagram the day after the
Oscars and a few months later after the
Oscar winner was banned from attending
any Academy events for a decade he said
sorry again in an emotional video shared
to YouTube I've reached out to
Chris
and the mesh the message that came back
is that he's not ready to talk and when
he is he will reach out I'm here
whenever you're ready to talk but a
source who knows both will and
crapologize directly to Chris and a
Second Source tells E.T Chris has no
interest in talking to will he believes
silence is the best response in this
case he doesn't believe Will's public
apology is sincere or Genuine of course
Chris's Netflix special marks the first
time the comedian spoken publicly about
the Oscar slap people like didn't hurt
it still hurts
I got summertime ringing in my ears I
was just glad to see after what happened
and all the trauma and stuff that he
emerged stronger I'm glad he's getting a
chance to be seen and appreciated
ET Source says that while Will and Jada
haven't watched the special they have
heard about the jokes and expected them
as for Chris a source previously told
E.T he said everything he wanted to say
and now he's ready to move on
[Music]
thank you